I always found boards to be one of the
most fascinating characters in the book
and now the movie because he isn't
necessarily the best influence but he
also kind of is so what is your favorite
quality about Boris that you would
pocket and take with you if you could
that's a good question
his commitment is a really big one which
is high up there well I'm not sure it's
that fun I think he's him being so
unpredictable being unpredictable is a
great thing to be I think maybe not in
the sense have been unpredictable and
hurting others unpredictable in the
sense of having fun and being
spontaneous that's a great quality I am
a creature of habit so I'm going to take
that to heart okay you have worked with
quite the assortment of filmmakers over
the years I mean Crowley I knew Qi
Knowland do you notice any shared traits
amongst the greats one they did they
know how to simply tell story and
storytelling is it forgotten art I think
now I think people get so kind of caught
up with the the gimmicks and the and all
the tools are begin I have you know when
we make movies and stories now and they
just keep it very simple there's a
through line with all these lovely
colors and branches coming off it and
you honor that and people will enjoy and
they do their homework they're not
figuring things out on the day you know
bang nine o'clock seven o'clock in the
morning twelve o'clock at night they're
like right now you know you go then you
like I'm confused about no no no it's
okay support that they they feed
everyone they feed the designers they
feed the the crew they feed the actors
involved and being able to be in that
position and have confidence and know
the story that you're making is going to
be solid and have belief in that that's
the great so you go into this super
prepared with a leader like Jon at the
helm but we're there any moments where
that kind of happy magic came out of
something you know something wasn't
going right but all of a sudden it
sparked something that you never even
knew was gonna come out of a scene yeah
but in a really different way so Jon
would say we've got
the scene and it was on the first day
filming that I did and I went can I just
have one for the road
and he was that okay you know you know a
lot of actors asked for more and more
takes I don't I just like I always like
to give a wild card so that was my
vision of saying I'd like a wild card so
I just said to him I went you know one
for the road and then that became a
thing throughout the whole shoot so
every time we eat got his takes he cone
I one for the road so then and that was
his direction to me I have a feeling you
might have been asked us today but this
is one of my favorite qualities of the
book so I kind of have to is just what
the Goldfinch the painting represents to
someone it's not just a practically
priceless piece of art hanging in a
museum it's filling a void in someone's
life its history and real meaning to it
so do you have any objects or things in
your life like that that are basically
your Goldfinch I have many different
things I'm trying to think of something
different so I can think of something
that I haven't said I knew that was
gonna come up a lot because it's tricky
but I wear mine around my neck every
single day all right well I tell you
what I've got actually is well I'm just
gonna tell you it's this ring and this
ring my mother gave me a necklace many
years ago when I first started traveling
around doing what I love doing and it
was here kind of going I'm always with
you
and I'm always supporting you and I
melted it down and I'm and then when I
met my my wife before we were married
I got her father's first wedding ring he
gave that to me and I melted that down
put them together to join the families
and now that's my wedding ring I'm so
this is so beautiful I don't care how
many people you told that today I'm glad
I have that honor okay